[Music]
stop what you're doing and stop
Spider-Man
sector four
do I uh have web on my face what's still
miles but he's right there he's like
turn around
black
let me guess he died
oh my gosh I'm learning so much from her
oh yeah I've learned a lot of stuff too
I'm leveled up my whole things
[Music]
the whole thing was his idea
okay
[Music]
look at me
huh miles hey who's the new guy
I'm sorry who are you I'm glad you asked
you guys my name is
this is where the traffic is this is
also where the traffic is the traffic
here too being Spider-Man is so easy I
fight a few bad guys quick break for Ty
with my my auntie I love chai tea what
did you just say
[Music]
and across the spider verse exclusively
in movie theaters June 2nd okay
miles's grades are pretty good A and AP
Physics that's my little man
[Music]
after his uncle a minus in English she's
a tough grader and a B in Spanish what
two okay
just missed a few classes oh just a few
classes well what's a few I mean you
know like
five five actually six you're dead my
name's Miles Morales I'm Brooklyn's one
and only Spiderman and things are going
great
he's gonna be here any minute should be
simple enough give me your money so are
you like a cow or a Dalmatian Spiderman
I am the spot
that's not funny
don't don't do that
there's bubbles now hold on
I don't think I want this costume
anymore in a minute hey what did all
this one word that's cute right the
youth
how's this going nice
grades are pretty good A and AP Physics
that's my little man and a B in Spanish
what okay miles
bye
miles
wanna get out of here
welcome to spider Society
I'm Spider-Man oh no way all of us are
Miguel O'Hara she's like a ninja vampire
Spider-Man but a good guy plus he's like
such a good leader miles there's moments
in our stories that are the same for all
of us some good did you bring our baby
to another fight I knew I was gonna
regret making her that web shooter you
asked me not to so I didn't I wouldn't
it's in bed you have a choice between
saving one person and saving every word
to me that's an obvious choice send me
home I can't do that I can do both all
stations stop Spiderman
[Music]
everyone keeps telling me how my story
is supposed to go
nah I'm gonna do my own thing
can this day get weirder
I guess it can
there's nowhere to run sorry
my bad everybody there was somewhere to
run